il y à des boules ici avec des chiffres
qui correspondent à des personnes du
public
c'est très simple vous allez prendre
venir près de moi on est dépassé vous et
isabelle elle laissera là dans une heure
ces présidentielles et bien aller comme
ça chacun une boule innus chaque boule
tirée sera gagné un téléspectateur un
spectateur pour chaque boule tirée
il y aura un cadeau donc vous allez
tirer au t4 on est comme matisse
aujourd'hui donc 10 boules celui qui
aura elles sont numérotées
celui qui aura le plus grand nombre
affrontera en finale am simplement
d'accord c'est vrai que nous avons des
boules que sur des boules exactement je
vous le dis il y aura des cadeaux pour
chaque personne du public je vais dire
les cadeaux dans un instant je crois que
je peux avoir un smartphone pour chaque
personne et il aura lots ray lors de la
finale il y aura séjours à gagner
1 c'est parti
baby you and your attention je vais
demander à mamie de ce recul est à 6 m
le numéro 4 à madame voilà très bien
joué et bouleversé bien là cette dame
gagna smartphone bon par contre vous
avez peu de chance vous allez castaldi
vient la motion bas moi c'est une donne
ta boule c'est bien la première fois que
tu le feras castaldi
[Applaudissements]
monsieur 203 vous gagnez un smartphone
également allé castaldi de qualité tu te
mets devant un vecteur numéro ses 103
vas-y vas-y mon bac termine bientôt
numéro devant toi comme ça les boules
ah ben on aime bien
matthieu delormeau et qu'il va faire
plus que castaldi pas mal 86 mais cette
semaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe clément pas
démonter les banques les banquiers à du
gros gros scoop voulons vite il avait
coup tous les mercredis de faire ça ok
mans comment d'aubrac 104 104 103 il
faut faire 104,68 annuel
[Applaudissements]
alors génial si c'est vrai ma boule
atomique des sports c'est parti ce
mortel
tonnes de riz
allez-y faut battre il faut battre 103
et 104 personnes dont trois sur
autoroutes et animatrice
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette la 407 kenya smartphones va
lontano smartphone moshiri torse et
chaises alias ans est à batz et kelly
vdo v10 poste 105 aulas pour l'instant
c'est toujours kelly vdev dit qui est en
finale face à moi c'est qu'il a
peut-être partir loin de tout ça le
donne
[Applaudissements]
tout en bas âge à mettre au milieu les
gars de babya qu'on met à battre
sans ces fonds seraient en fait c'est le
centquatre et enfin jean michel le seul
qui peut battre les loosers
que ce soit dans les premiers tours 43
car là le temps 3 mas a également un
smartphone maintenant c'est la finale
entre quellier moi ou alors gagner
peut-être votre premier point si kelly
perd ce sera terminé bien longtemps dans
le demain vous ferez directement votre
gageons début d'émission
si kelly qu'à aller pour reviendraient à
2 points et l'épreuve de demain comptera
double et qu'il y peut décider de donner
sa place à quelqu'un d'autre pour la
finale non magique du tout non non elle
a desserré je demande à tout public de
se lever carré de peau les deux
personnes qui seront tirés bien entendu
ceux qui ont déjà été tirés avons pas de
trop tirer une deuxième cas dit allez-y
à l'élite asie qu'elle y aller il y aura
donc deux séjours à gagner la chance
avec toi aller et je vous rappelle que
je dois faire plus que key
sachez
que le nombre cas thierry quelques
chiffres kathy ricklin c'est dans les 70
donc tous les autres pautrel et dans les
70 c'est bien c'est pas ou est ce donc
dix personnes
ça n'est pas le soixante dix abris
nation sans toi qu'elle se dispute ce
soir ça n'est pas le 71 ça n'est pas le
73 à ahvaz et syndicats ça n'est pas le
74 à ça n'est pas le 75 ac72
ça n'est pas le 76 bas sans surprise à
n'est pas le 77 pro l'animateur ça n'est
pas le 78 des vingt ans laisse un temps
mal à vous à quoi 72 et vous 79 une de
vous deux à gagner 1 voyage
voilà le week-end c'est 79
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non et bien maintenant bravo ma chérie
tu vas partir à qui tu peux me montrer
du doigt c'est lui très bien merci je
suis très bien je suis très content que
tu partes avec lui attention je dois
battre je dois battre le 79 et en plus
il y a bien sûr un smartphone etc et
tout le public peut se lever à nous à
main du vainqueur faisait pas fâché
que tous ceux
ils sont dans les trente peuvent
s'asseoir dans les travaux de s'asseoir
tous ceux qui sont dans les quarante
peuvent s'asseoir tous ceux qui sont
dans les 10 peuvent s'asseoir olala
graciet tous ceux qui sont dans les 50
peuvent s'asseoir au l'inventaire dans
les 60 pas de 500 dans les 70's peuvent
s'asseoir des gens ceux qui sont dans
les 80 qui sont dans les 90 rap ça soit
assez dur tu as fait une école
d'animation lo ya ceux qui sont dans les
sens peuvent s'asseoir dernière ligne
droite dans les rôles du père dans l'âme
elle perd jamais il n'a pas dit de les
héros donc peuvent s'asseoir depuis le 4
août son gré chéri partie red bull
j'ai une bonne et mauvaise nouvelle j
pareil la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
j'ai malheureusement perdu le hockey
mais c'était pas rêver que de 71 donc
les chroniqueurs reviennent à deux
points d'un avocat
je vais demander à tous ceux qui sont
dans les vins le rester debout
les autres peuvent s'asseoir car il ya
un séjour en europe a gagné ces gens
l'institution jour je vais demander au
28 de s'asseoir ça n'est pas le 28 ce
n'est pas le 29
ça n'est pas le 26 janet pas le 21
ça n'est pas le 22
y'a quoi monsieur
25 24 25 23 pas que ce soir là vannes
seul combien tu peux t'asseoir 27 tu peu
d'humanité il reste donc 24 25
cette copine vous serez fait celle vous
êtes collègues et copines et sa part je
vous laisse une chance d'échanger vos
tickets
[Applaudissements]
vous échangez vos tickets ne pourraient
pas partir ensemble
alors voilà cette appellation biologique
[Rires]
a les pieds 25 25 cents à kehl 24 à ce
tarif on bat c je ne me souviens plus
vous allez partir pour un séjour en
europe en france enfin le numéro gagnant
rechange et c'est
cal 25
cyril oui pour mettre un effet comme
j'ai été leader tnt c'est pas bien je
vienne d'annoncer non seulement 24 ans
à cuba il était bon de faire merci
légère